hey everyone it's sarah with
registerednessrn.com and in this video
i'm going to demonstrate how to start a
peripheral iv
before performing any nursing skills you
want to make sure that you're following
your hospital's protocols
to ensure you're following the latest
guidelines
before inserting the iv first what you
want to do is you want to gather your
supplies and perform hand hygiene
then after that you want to prepare your
supplies and find a vein that you want
to use on your patient to actually
insert the iv
in once you have done that you'll
perform hand hygiene
don gloves and then prepare for
insertion so here we have actually
trimmed the patient's hair and sometimes
you have to do this
because what will happen is whenever you
go to secure it
the tape will not stick to the patient
it'll roll off over time
and then plus whenever you go to remove
the ivy it'll be very painful to that
person who has a lot of hair
so we have used trimmers that have just
trimmed it
you don't ever want to use like a
straight razor so use whatever trimming
supplies
that your facility has so now i'm ready
to insert the iv
and i've applied the tourniquet so the
vein that we're going to go in
is in the hand we're going to go right
there so before we even stick the vein
we first have to disinfect the site and
we're going to use the kits
chloraprep that it comes with and
depending on what type of kit you have
will depend on what it looks like
so with this particular one we're going
to take this and just
push it together and you'll hear that
cracking noise that's just releasing all
the core prep
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
start in the center and i'm going to
work my way outward
we're going to clean the site for about
30 seconds and then we're going to let
it completely
dry so in the center
and i'm cleaning we're going to clean
for 30 seconds
now the site has completely dried so i'm
ready to stick the vein
so what i'm going to do first is i want
to stabilize this vein i don't want it
to roll away on me
so i'm going to go below the area where
i cleaned and i'm just going to
pull on the skin which will help
stabilize the vein
then i'm going to hold my iv i'm holding
it with my thumb and index finger at
that area
and i'm going to hold it bevel up
and i'm going to go in at give or take
about a 20 degree angle
and i'm going in the way that the vein
is naturally made because we
just want this plastic cannula to slide
in there
okay so here we go you're going to feel
a sharp
stick okay
okay i have blood return and you can see
that
in the chamber right there now remember
i want to go
just a hair bit more okay i'm there
so now what i'm going to do is i'm going
to thread
this off it's in there so now after that
i want to pop the tourniquet
and i'm going to take my finger and i
want to apply firm pressure
because i don't want to leak out then
i'm going to hit the safety button
and it's going to remove the needle and
then i'm going to connect the access
device
so i'm going to connect this and then
twist this on make sure that is nice and
secure when you do this
because you don't want it to get loose
so first i'm going to check for blood
return
and we have it then i'm going to
flush the ivy i'm going to flush using a
push
pause flush i'm going to flush in about
three to five cc so i'm gonna do
one to two cc's pause flush again one to
two
and i'm looking at the site it's not
bubbling up which would mean
infiltration
and how does the site feel to you feels
fine it doesn't hurt okay
and it looks great and because we're
using a neutral
displacement cap there's no sequence
required so i'm just going to clamp it
off and then i'm just going to undo this
but let's say that this is a positive
pressure
cap well with this it would change my
sequence with how i would clamp like for
instance
i would flush and then i would
disconnect
from this cap with my flush and then i
would clamp you can also have
negative pressure and with those what
you would do is flush
then you would clamp and then disconnect
so just be familiar with the type of
device you're using
and we're going to secure with our
dressing i'm just going to lay
that there and i'm going to go ahead and
apply my keuros cap
just to protect the site
there we go so now we're going to secure
it
i'm going to with this particular
dressing you want to get familiar with
your kits what's in your kits because
everything's different
i'm going to take this part
off like so and i'm going to hold it at
this end
and has a notched area so i want this
part to lay
on the top of the cap where
before it goes in to the access the
extension
set so i'm just going to lay it there
i'm going to apply some firm pressure
just to get it down on the skin
okay so i'm securing that down
by touching it then what i want to do is
i want to slightly compress these sides
and i'm going to just lift this tubing
up just a little bit
because i want those notch parts to get
underneath that
part of the ivy
so i'm pressing everything down making
sure it's nice and secure
then what i'm going to do is i'm going
to tear off these edges around
the abbey this part right here
little edges
and then as you're doing that just push
it down make sure it sticks to the skin
because you don't want to lose your ivy
after you have started it
then what i'm going to do is i'm going
to take this part
of the tape this big piece
and i'm going to lay it across
this part so it just provides
extra securement so we have that there
i'm applying pressure
like that i'm just sealing it down
nice and sealed then with this
particular extension tubing
remember the letter j okay because
that's how you want to
secure it down we don't want this
flopping everywhere that's going to put
tension
on the ivy line causing possibly the iv
to slip out
and we want to protect it and then
there's this other piece of tape that
you will use
to secure the tail of the iv
so i've already went ahead and filled it
out i've put the insertion date here
put whatever date your facility requires
you to put so i'm going to peel
that off and i'm going to put this up
again in the
j shape and i'm going to lay that
there and i'm going to just take this
piece of tape
and just slide it on this part
and then be sure you smooth the edges
down
so that it sticks and that will just
help protect that site from
falling out and just keep it more secure
then dispose of this
in the receptacle area that your
facility requires you to dispose these
types of things in remove our gloves
perform hand hygiene and document okay
so that wraps up this video and if you
would like to watch
more videos on nursing skills you can
access the link in the youtube
description below